dealing with cobalt toxicity from bilateral hip implants 19 years ago while in the process
of hip revisions to remove the cobalt, do you recommend anything to help with heavy
metal detox? Systemically I think they meant. The thing is if you have the implants in your
body right now you can't do heavy metal detox so let's rephrase that answer. If you have
metal implants in your body that you're having issues with so it is leaching that metal into
your body so therefore you're having issues with it and you use a heavy key later so typically
in order to pull metal out of heavy metals out of your tissues you would use a key later now
understand. I have labeled that phase of detoxification as phase zero so I don't think you have any
business doing that for a couple of reasons. Number one if you still have the implants you should not
be doing any heavy key letters. That's like if you have mercury fillings and you're going to do heavy
keylation all you're going to be doing is pulling that possibly out of your teeth into your body.
It's just this is foolishness so you've got to not use heavy key letters. If you have a piece of
metal in your body and you're trying to and you're having a reaction to it you have to get the metal
removed and then you key late excess metal that is systemic in your body through key layers but you
don't do keylation therapy or or IV keylation therapy until you've supported the other six phases
of detoxification. I could buy more information on our website on the seven phases of detoxification
written a little short booklet on that. I have videos on that and I have a complete course of
the seven phases of detoxification quite quickly. You have to support everything else because if you're
going to key late it out of the tissue. You're pulling it out of the tissue. Where's it going?
It's going to the bloodstream and where's it going from there? It's not going to the toilet. It's going
through your liver. So then your liver has to take it through phase one two and three in your liver
get it placed into the bile and travels from the bile down the bile ducts stored in the gallbladder
and then it's transported into the small intestine. Then it's transported through 30 feet of intestines
and hopefully into the toilet. Now those all consist of what I call phase one two three four five
six and you don't have any business of keylating things out into the blood unless you support
in all those other phases of detoxification first or most likely you're just going to make yourself
sicker. So number one if you still have the implants to answer this person's question you should not
do any chelation. Once you get the implants removed and replaced with something safer then you
could do chelation but only after you've addressed those other six phases of detoxification. If you're
concurrent you can do this concurrently but you've got to deal with those other six phases of detoxification.
If you're really interested in our courses are I think the detox courses $49 or something like that
go on that it's be a good $49 spent to understand those phases to support those things.
It doesn't have to be difficult it doesn't have to be confusing but I tried to that's why I put the
course together to help you understand but I just seen over 30 years of doing this kind of stuff as
seeing people get sick doing a key later while I'm doing this detoxification program the key
late heavy metals my doctor put me on you know EDTA to pull out heavy metals and I just got super super
sick. That's because your liver was congested so all you do is pull them out with the EDTA which
actually works you pull it out of the tissues put it into the blood it had no room to get through
the liver because the liver was already congested so it just got deposited elsewhere it circulated
around cross maybe worse cross the blood barrier that's also damaged and you made yourself much worse
you'll want to do that so follow the seven phases of detoxification booklet or course
and that will be the way to go but in short you do not do keylation therapy at all if you have
the metal still in your body so that's just you just can't do that so you can support all the other
six phases of detoxification that can really help a lot but you can't any keylation therapy
excuse me while you got the metal in your body